(Light whimsical music)
- When I'd go to compete, I'd realize
there's not a lot of
people who look like me.
There's an opportunity here to encourage
and teach people how to sail.
My name is Ayme Sinclair.
I'm a sailor, and I'm
trying to open up sailing
so that it's a more diverse sport.
(Whimsical music)
(Waves crashing)
Turn. Ready?
Alright. Everybody ready?
Tacking!
(cable pulled through pulley)
I got into sailing four years ago.
I had a moment where I
was just really unhappy.
And the idea that I was able to come out
every Wednesday night and
sail with my teammates
was like my one place of happiness.
And I loved that.
It saved me when I was
in a really dark place.
Pull.
The team that I race with
now is called Sweet Caroline.
I love my teammates.
They're my family.
Half the team is women.
We represent eight different countries,
from Morocco to Peru, Jamaica,
to Columbia and India.
But, when I would go
to compete, I'd realize
we're the only team that looks like us.
Jay, can you put this in the locker?
One of the things that I wanted to do
was start a collective
channel called Sailing Noire,
an Instagram account,
so that I can get the word out about it
and encourage more people to join.
It wound up taking off,
a lot of people started
following and reaching out,
asking how they can learn.
I realized that there's
an opportunity here
to encourage and teach people how to sail.
So then I started traveling.
Hi, so my name is Ayme.
I am a competitive sailor from New York.
I would put together
different groups of people,
and we would go out and we
would sail for a couple days.
More recently, I went to Kenya.
I put together the first
ever women's sailing team.
And it was amazing.
- (woman) The first all-female
sailing team competing.
- One...two...three...winning!
- I decided we're going
to start a women's team;
we're going to join this race;
and we're going to show these
girls that they can do this.
And help these girls feel like they were
empowered to learn something new.
It was probably one of
the most amazing things
I've ever experienced in my life.
There were all these
women from this community
who never come out,
don't participate in sailing or boating,
which is two of the biggest drivers
of the economy on that island.
We changed the way a whole
community thinks about
women's role in society.
(Seagulls squawking) (Waves crashing)
(light whimsical music)
I think sailing should be
more inclusive and diverse,
because it's such a loss that
other people don't get to experience
the same thing that I do.
They're just not use to seeing us.
So we gotta fix that.
(Light whimsical music)
I would say try something new,
don't be afraid.
You will surprise yourself
when you realize you can do it.
And that feeling, you
can't put a price on that.
(Light whimsical music)